permettere alle persone e movimenti di
organizzarsi permettere alle persone di
essere visibili al di là di poteri e
potenti permettere alle persone di
convogliare consenso a volte di migliaia
milioni di persone sulla pagina web
della loro causa
luigi una mattina si sveglia con uno
strano mal di schiena mal di schiena
insolito insistente va a fare gli
accertamenti del caso si trova davanti
un dottore che guarda e riguarda quelle
risonanze lunghissimi minuti di silenzio
prima della diagnosi tumore una diagnosi
che ti toglie il fiato
la speranza il futuro
il tumore di luigi non è operabile e non
risponde alle terapie tradizionali
chemioterapia radioterapia il tumore di
luigi risponde alla dro terapia una
terapia disponibile soltanto in quattro
centri al mondo
e pensate uno di questi centri si trova
a pavia luigi vive in piemonte tutto
sommato il centro si trova a una
manciata di chilometri eppure il sistema
sanitario nazionale non copre
l'adroterapia non è una terapia
salvavita e quindi è disponibile
soltanto per i cittadini residenti in
lombardia
che cosa fareste voi al suo posto
la prima cosa che ho pensato è stata
cambiasse residenza ma luigi non è così
luigi non ama le scorciatoie i
sotterfugi luigi crede di avere diritto
a l'unica terapia che può salvargli la
vita
e quindi fa delle ricerche
su internet va su www.change.gov in home
page trova un grande bottone rosso
lancio alla tua petizione clicca
racconta la sua storia fa la sua
richiesta la indirizza al giusto
decisore nel giro di dieci giorni
raccoglie oltre 100 mila firme
la sua storia fa il giro del web finisce
sui media tradizionali tante persone gli
scrivono dimostrando solidarietà si
mette in contatto con lui
la commissione della sanità della
regione piemonte
gli dicono che vaglieranno il caso 25
giorni dopo esattamente luigi riceve una
telefonata da parte di un rappresentante
di quella commissione
l'adroterapia è stata riconosciuta come
terapia salvavita e finalmente luigi
potrà dedicare tutte le sue energie alla
cosa più importante
curarsi perché vi ho raccontato questa
storia perché questa storia ha
innanzitutto proprio grazie alla persona
come luigi che non si è affermato al suo
orticello non ha cercato scorciatoie
sotterfugi ha messo a disposizione la
sua storia per tutti ha permesso a tutte
le persone nella sua stessa situazione
di venire allo scoperto ha permesso che
si parlasse di qualcosa di cui prima non
si parlava e quindi questa storia
personale che è diventata una storia
sociale di tutti è per noi
emblematica del nostro impatto ma
soprattutto emblematica della missione
di change.org
change.org è nata da un'idea quella di
dare la possibilità a tutti i cittadini
di proporre il cambiamento che vogliono
vedere nel mondo è nata nel 2007 in
california nella culla delle start up
delle web corporation come google e
facebook è nata da un'idea di baratri
che a soli 33 anni è stato indicato dal
times come uno degli uomini più
influenti al mondo uno dei 100 uomini
più influenti al mondo change.org ha
vinto il web worker me più importante
sito di attivismo online e oggi alla più
grande petizione di petizioni online con
150 milioni di utenti a livello globale
5 milioni e 700 mila in italia quando ho
iniziato a lavorare per questa
piattaforma nel novembre 2012
venivo da un misto di esperienze nel
terzo settore nella comunicazione online
blogging fotografia di viaggio
questo si prospettava essere per me un
po il lavoro che avrebbe fuso quelle due
anime e si prospettava essere un lavoro
molto bello per me ma ci misi un po
esattamente a capire che cosa stessimo
effettivamente facendo in che direzione
stessimo andando e non avrei mai creduto
che avremmo avuto l'impatto che stiamo
avendo non avrei mai creduto che saremmo
diventati così grandi non ci credevo
perché la mobilitazione l'aggregazione
passava principalmente attraverso i
canali prestabiliti dei partiti politici
dei sindacati della chiesa non ci
credevo perché le istanze dei cittadini
si scontravano contro istituzioni sorde
spesso contro muri di colma burocratica
eppure meno di quattro anni dopo santo
questa piattaforma un po come
un figlio un figlio che è diventato
grande che cammina ora sulle sue gambe
un figlio che ha vissuto la fase piu
rapida del suo sviluppo esattamente
nell'ultimo anno come se fosse stato
adolescente nell'ultimo anno era il
dicembre 2014 quando festeggiammo il
raggiungimento dei 3 milioni di utenti e
poco più di un anno dopo ci trovavamo a
festeggiare il traguardo di 5 milioni di
utenti
grazie al numero importante che ha
stupito anche me però non è il numero
che mi sta più a cuore il numero che mi
sta più a cuore quello delle petizioni
che hanno raggiunto quello che
chiedevano ed è 600 in meno di quattro
anni in italia soltanto e se alziamo lo
sguardo a livello globale ci accorgeremo
che quasi una petizione loro raggiunge
il suo scopo è il meccanismo è proprio
questo persone che mettono a
disposizione la loro storia personale
per un cambiamento che sia di tutti come
giannina giannina una figlia di 6 anni
stella la perde in un terribile
incidente stradale causato da un uomo
drogato o ubriaco alla guida di un'auto
rubata senza patente
non se lo spiega non si rassegna non c'è
niente che possa in qualche modo colmare
quel vuoto e canalizza tutta questa
rabbia e questa disperazione anche lei
sul nostro sito
mi ricordo la prima volta che ho parlato
con lei ecco c'era quasi solo rabbia se
ha bisogno di lavoro per canalizzare
quella rabbia in qualcosa di propositivo
che poi è arrivato qualcosa mi disse
giannino al telefono quando si parla i
la prima volta che renda un pochino meno
vanno alla morte di stella si può essere
d'accordo o meno con il reato di
omicidio stradale ma la sua introduzione
recente in italia non lo sappiamo ma in
parte dovuta giannina giannina che un
anno prima dell'introduzione di questo
tipo di reato con la fiducia aveva
consegnato le firme
della sua petizione in senato e al
ministero dei trasporti strappando al
ministero dei trasporti una promessa
entro un anno
voglio delle risposte concrete che
funzionino da deterrente
da ora in poi per le persone che si
mettono alla guida senza pensare a
quello che stanno facendo nel dolore che
possono recare ad altri e quindi ecco
questo è quello che ha creato giannina
dal dolore ha creato un movimento
la petizione online è stata la punta
dell'iceberg di un movimento di genitori
nella sua stessa situazione che ha
riunito sotto le sedi delle istituzioni
preposte ad ascoltare la sua richiesta
oppure vi potrei raccontare di sabri
sabrina safi una donna che è arrivata in
italia dall'iran 35 anni fa è arrivata
quando l'ayatollah khomeini ordinò alle
donne di indossare il velo impose tutta
una serie di misure estremamente
costrittive per una donna come lei
libera per tutte le donne come lei
sabry era attivista in iran continua ad
essere attivista con gli strumenti che
aveva a disposizione qui in italia
e quando si rese conto che aveva il web
a disposizione inizio a utilizzarlo
sabry legge di un blogger iraniano
condannato a morte per un posto ritenuto
offensivo su facebook nei confronti di
momento lancia una petizione anche la
sua petizione fa il giro del web viene
tradotta in inglese e in francese e
raccoglie oltre 260 mila firme a quel
punto ha bisogno di un aiuto ma il gioco
è fatto
il circolo virtuoso si è innescato
perché lei non è gradita in ambasciata
lei vorrebbe depositare le sue firme in
ambasciata iraniana
quindi le viene incontro luigi manconi
presidente
della commissione diritti umani al
senato in italia e si offre volontario
per prendere in carico queste firme e
consegnarle all'ambasciatore luigi
manconi ottiene dall'ambasciatore una
promessa entro due settimane una
risposta è quella risposta arriva
l'ambasciatore lo richiama di comunica
che è stato deciso che la condanna a
morte nei confronti del blogger su el
arabi verrà sospesa e pochi mesi dopo è
arrivata la definitiva cancellazione
della condanna a morte
perché vi ho raccontato queste storie
sono storie di persone qualunque forti
soltanto in virtù di quello che
raccontano e grazie a quello che
raccontano quello che propongono sono
storie di persone che fino a qualche
anno fa non avrebbero potuto aver voce
non avrebbero potuto verbose se non
avessero conosciuto rappresentanti delle
istituzioni o giornalisti con volontà di
aiutarli
oggi possono raccontarsi non più in
maniera passiva ma in maniera attiva
possono come ho già detto mettere la
loro storia al servizio di un movimento
di tutti di un cambiamento per tutti
le storie di sabri giannina luigi hanno
raggiunto il loro obiettivo come tante
altre ma molte non raggiungeranno
ovviamente quello che si prefiggono
tuttavia tutte queste storie
contribuiranno innanzitutto lasceranno
un segno profondo nella memoria
collettiva di 5 milioni e 700mila
italiani e contribuiranno a cambiare la
percezione di questi italiani cambiare
il loro rapporto con la realtà mediatica
con la realtà politica sociale con la
vita contribuiranno a fare in modo che
non si credano più degli spettatori ma
capiscono di avere la possibilità di
essere degli attori nel mondo che li
circonda perché ognuno di noi attore del
cambiamento che stiamo vivendo
ognuno di noi è il cambiamento
grazie